where is Ahsoka heading what's next for
Snips you just finished watching Ahsoka
and you're curious about the future of
the Star Wars franchise well look no
further than Dave filoni's upcoming
Standalone Star Wars film rumored to be
titled heir to the Empire the movie is
expected to follow the aftermath of the
Disney plus series Ahsoka and wrap up
the events of the Mandalorian in the
book of Boba Fett by the end of this
video I'll make sure you know everything
we know so far about Dave filoni's
upcoming movie and the future of Ahsoka
Tano Star Wars heir to the Empire is a
novel by Timothy Zahn that was published
in 1991. it was one of the first Star
Wars spin-off books to be released
following many others and a long-running
Marvel comic series but heir to the
Empire is one of the stories that
defined the Star Wars expanded universe
it was one of the first stories to show
what happened to Luke Skywalker and
Princess Leia after Return of the Jedi
heir to the Empire takes place five
years after that movie when the new
Republic is trying to establish itself
as the Galaxy's new government the
Empire is still around but not as strong
as before and that becomes clear when
Granny Admiral thrawn resurfaces and
starts to rebuild his army using a mix
of secret Imperial technology and old
clone wars era Fleet and his own
brilliant tactics thrawn manages to
overthrow the new Republic once again
it's up to Luke Leia and Han Solo to
save the Galaxy heir to the Empire
introduces several important new
characters besides thrawn himself this
novel is where Readers first meet Mara
Jade a former assassin who used to be
known as the emperor's hand and a woman
who has a close connection to Luke
himself it also introduces Talon card a
new Smuggler becomes very rich and
Powerful after a job of the Hutt's death
heir to the Empire is part of a Trilogy
called the thrawn trilogy which also
includes 1992's dark force rising and
1993 is the last command together these
three books are one of the most popular
parts of the Star Wars expanded universe
heir to the Empire and its sequels have
had a huge impact on the Star Wars
franchise they were part of a series
called Dark Empire along with Dark Horse
Comics that set the standard for all
post Return of the Jedi Star Wars
stories in the 90s many of these stories
follow the same plot with the new
Republic trying to recover only to face
a new enemy from an imperial warlord who
wants to restore Palpatine's Empire
thrawn himself became a legendary
villain one of the few expanded universe
characters who can match the movie
villains His Brilliant mind and complex
motives made him a standout among a
crowd of angry Sith Lords and space
criminals it's no wonder author Timothy
Zahn has kept writing new thrawn novels
over the years both in the expanded
universe and in the new Disney Canon
even though Disney moved heir to the
Empire and the rest of the expanded
universe to Legend status it's clear
these movies are still influencing the
franchise thrawn himself was finally
confirmed in the third season of the
Animated Series Star Wars Rebels and now
actor Lars Mickelson is playing him
again in the live-action series Ahsoka
even when it comes to how we see the
post-return of the Jedi Star Wars
Universe what we're seeing in shows like
the Mandalorian matches what was shown
in heir to the Empire once again this is
a time when the new Republic is trying
to rebuild and maintain peace in the
Galaxy even as Imperial Warlords try to
rally their forces and regain power but
some things have changed from the
expanded universe Han and Leia had three
children in the EU instead of one son in
the Disney verse and the Clone Wars as
it's shown in heir to the Empire is a
completely different war from what
George Lucas would start later in his
prequel movies for the most part art
however the Mandalorian and Ahsoka share
a lot with the air to the Empire series
and that may be why an heir to the
Empire movie is likely the Dave filoni
team is already working on a movie set
in this time period as we've seen the
Galaxy during the Mandalorian and Ahsoka
is very similar to heir to the Empire we
don't know much about filoni Star Wars
movie yet but we do know that it
connects all the shows and characters
set in this era of Star Wars everything
these shows have been exploring from the
tragic fate of Mandalore to ahsoka's
hunt for thrawn and Ezra Bridger is
meant to pay off in one big screen
Adventure it was announced during Star
Wars celebration that Dave filoni would
be directing a new feature film that
would be the end of all the storyline
set up by the Mandalorian the book of
Boba Fett and Ahsoka but is and the
right word in a recent interview with
Empire magazine polony talked about how
that word fits his film end is an
interesting word the way I look at it
there are small stories and then there's
the big story of the day too A New Hope
Empire and Return of the Jedi tell the
important parts of the tale that really
Define the history of the period there
are all kinds of sub stories beneath
that we've been building all of these
small stories as a went on to explain
the movie will be focused around a big
event something that changes what's
happening in time think of Luke blowing
up the Death Star Vader telling Luke
he's his father the defeat of the Empire
and here's what he said about that to me
a theatrical experience has to have a
big idea a Monumental moment in the time
period that changes what's happening
what Tony Gilroy has done in Andor what
we did in Rebels everything then changes
when Luke blows up the Death Star you're
looking for those moments that define an
era and that's what the films really
should be about whether it's characters
coming together or a defining moment it
makes sense to put all this conflict
around thrawn himself he's the perfect
villain for a movie involving din jarin
Ahsoka Boba Fett and the Rangers of the
new Republic he's one of the last
remnants of Palpatine's Empire who wants
to regain his power and stop the growing
New Republic we know from the Star Wars
sequels that this won't happen but that
doesn't mean thrawn can't cause real
damage to the Galaxy before he's
defeated just like in the air to the
Empire novels in fact it's possible
filoni's movie could actually be called
heir to the Empire Ahsoka even uses that
phrase to describe thrawn in the Ahsoka
series lucasfilm clearly wants the term
heir to the Empire to be at the
Forefront of our minds for a reason not
every detail is exactly the same as the
novel but there's enough commonality
between the events of the novel and the
Disney Plus shows that it makes sense to
adapt air to the Empire with epic
battles and dire Stakes there's a reason
heir to the Empire remains one of the
most beloved Star Wars novels it's
perfect for the film treatment and that
day May finally be coming if felony is
really making an heir to the Empire
movie one of the biggest questions
everyone has is whether Luke Skywalker
will be in it Luke is definitely one of
the most important characters in the
novel which is set a few years before he
fully commits himself to rebuilding the
Jedi Order at this point Luke is still
traveling the Galaxy and serving as one
of the new Republic's most Brave
Defenders we've seen Luke in both the
Mandalorian and the Book of Boba Fett
the latter of which showed Luke in the
very early stages of creating his Jedi
Academy on Asus he's a character with a
small but important role to play in
these shows which could also mean he has
a chance to appear in the felony movie
maybe lucasfilmove improved its digital
Mark Hamill Recreation by then Luke's
role in the Star Wars sequels was
controversial to to say the least not
all fans were happy with finding out
that his Jedi Academy failed nor were
they pleased to see that Luke had become
a milk drinking always grumpy Jedi
hermit even if he was just following
Yoda and Obi-Wan's example many fans
have been eager to see Luke Skywalker in
his prime fighting to keep peace in the
era of the new Republic the sequels
couldn't give them that but maybe
filoni's movie can however this
storyline could work with another
character like former Jedi Ahsoka Tano
as a substitute for Luke she could be
the key to defeating thrawn whether or
not filoni's movie is actually called
heir to the Empire The Hope is that it
can continue the example set by the
Mandalorian in the book of Boba Fett the
Star Wars franchise may have a bit of a
Skywalker Obsession but this is one case
where Luke's presence may actually make
sense show us Luke Skywalker at his best
and most heroic give us a cinematic team
up between Luke and Ahsoka with a
villain as imposing as Grand Admiral
thrawn the Galaxy needs its greatest
heroes to win the day thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]
thank you